at 5:00 a.m. that's 6 a.m. excuse me 6
a.m. tip basketball New York City a
bunch of dudes 6:00 in the morning
crack up on it
but I don't like about that this
interview is I didn't know the angle
right so make sure you at least know
what the potential headline is or where
it's going that would happen good
morning welcome have a good day yeah 26
minutes a pure goal I think they just
you know that it's 20 minutes at a time
they go buy it so I get back over just
that chat and push towards it I know
census so your snap this morning yeah
how you like that you got potential kid
you're in the episode oh boy the bond is
filming today the rocks editing for
Stefan's filming 5 as we speak hey my
boy yeah how are you
I like this how are you so good to you
where if you make a four-minute video
that's high emotion and we retarget to
87,000 people that watched all four
minutes there in the franchise if we go
right hook right behind it with a call
to action and get back into the bundle
they will convert it's good
old-fashioned marketing I stood up
because I'm excited let me call honest I
mean for one other thing you're gonna be
super pumped about that I have a funny
feeling all of you about going to look
good on TV
it's good right now help me with the
following this is the most important
question for my dream how many of those
people do you have more than email which
means you have their phone number phone
number no no I would call every one of
your customers although I'm telling you
right now that if you called these
people and said thank you for ever being
a customer that's it and I'm not joking
when I say this I do not mean thank you
and your some offer reactivate I
literally mean I'm Sally and this is
this requires you have to it's not so
easy at scale so is it 12 bucks an
hour's of 14 is it nine like you're
gonna have to find this magic because
you need bodies this is called scaling
the unscalable which is something no
company ever wants to do I think you
could find something pretty remarkable
having
mash is taking a restaurant break room
you know it's funny I I do edit myself
in front of the camera I would have said
something very different
have you gotten that at all Gare have
you felt like people added himself
something pretty good
oh I'm talking other people yeah 20 I
caught myself um editing myself just now
you're gonna end up being a better guy
or a worse guy not the realest form of
myself it just sounded so vulgar I was
gonna say that taking a piss such a
sensible oh my secret so they don't mind
but Bob I'm better guy than Stefan Gary
and I steam select yeah so emergency
that room yeah room I should've Ives it
hurts and last you were real good I mean
when you have and Emacs Bassett brand
bar on our team this should be this
should be miss a pick and switch score
three four big buckets on the world in a
row on that yeah we can manage a weak
link
don't put that on camera poor world but
know that actually a 100% white man
sorry Jeff you didn't play great this
morning hey guys keep close the door at
least you know
how you doing
see you again just under L&T of the
layers you have my sneakers great
alright just came back because yeah I
did anything are you on a bit of hockey
I'm sorry okay yeah thanks
I am so I did a recording a daily blog
for the last four I've done four
episodes so far so da clearly
documenting my business days Chloe's
gonna join as well I'm gonna not be
alive I mean I read this up down similar
Chloe hi Cody I couldn't mega to me yeah
the only religion I have his attention
of February 2006
I watched something called Wine Library
TV and hundreds of thousands of people
watched it I'm fiddler not even on
YouTube his own liquor business done
yeah I still in a wine shop called Wine
Library it's in Short Hills New Jersey
on this episode I get weird when did
they put this out today cuz I was up
gary vay-ner-chuk I got it
this is Daymond John the P owes sharp
but I also know that I am a huge fan of
the show that kind of reminds me of when
Oh
dr. evil said who here's what the bar
job anyway don't worry about it so now
you know I have my new book out called
the power of broke d-roc do me a favor
can you just uh put that link up in
sprinkly you're not getting some love
it's the funniest
nobody talked about not the other none
there's another opportunity in the
Indian on something else is coming in
like it's an Instagram snapchat project
okay let's spend more time ones on one's
emails you might you know please like
not because I'm trying to hack a couple
of views on the daily be stuff like get
into where my psychology is on this
understand because I think you know my
show and now this day love you think I'm
getting to scale out of it right like
the I was able to instead of doing it
all hands-on get a lot of people aligned
where my snapchat POV is belly so I'm
trying to think about these things I
don't care how you want to do it you
want to get a roofie or cool you know
like I don't care how but what has not
happened in 2015 with a lot of you I
mean has to happen in 2016 with a lot of
you which is you just have to ask me a
couple more questions
you just need clarity from me I'm super
available that's like the [ __ ]
shittiest part of this whole rant right
which is like I mean it like I'm not
just saying and then like [ __ ] I hope
they don't hit me up right so please use
me I want to be used must have changed
my mind every day I mean serious the
market put like I'm a marketplace
operator like I just had this
impassionate like cool but in like four
months of be like okay we're about to do
it like you know so like what's that you
know I don't need a doughnut alright
your oxy shuffle dance this fashion oh
god this is plums no plums are delicious
the rocks are [ __ ] really good [ __ ] you
the character yeah ah you're Jeff here
I'll get this [ __ ]
super cool to meet that kids
I told AG I got together I've been
mentoring Patrick for a while the fact
that he was you know it widened did
their incubator program at sixteen with
some cool [ __ ] I was like you know what
this is a kid that I can get close to so
we've been spending a lot of time
together this is something you want to
sell or something that you want to drop
somewhere and operate it we're doing
yeah it's fresh it's not like like a
division of yeah okay great you baited
from within yeah yeah so you guys are
natural fit who are you already doing so
what's the story 19 years old real
hustler and what kind of kid were you
like a like a TAC building kid like math
kid like what wouldn't what what are you
I've heard a business was fake IDs
that's a good start good I love when I
asked about what his first business was
fake IDs I love that game he was grinded
and I hate websites for an armored
profit yeah I'm just going down low why
you need to like make amends it just
reminds me of like back in the day it's
fun to have meetings like that and
remember like the early days like having
the whole world of business in front of
you you know I [ __ ] hated school so
having that opportunity to like get into
the next chapter of my life was
incredible I really enjoyed it smart kid
um I love kind of sizing myself up to
like smart young kids felt like I
understood what he was talking about and
I like that I like that whole demeanor I
just really wish him well trying to
preach him patience cuz that's the
biggest thing I don't have that age but
for me to like for me to ever do
anything I always want to know what
somebody wants to happen right so so
like I'm trying to really figure out
your patience level your interest level
like like all this stuff is very easy
for me that you're saying mainly because
I already did it once for myself so I
understand the levers and things of that
nature what I'm trying to think about
believe it or not is the three to five
years from now the transition really
hope you guys noticed by the way real
quick my question about the five-year
plan for him always trying to use that
as I don't think 5-year plans are
practical in today's world but try to
use that as a proxy of trying to
understand what's up where somebody's
heads
I think it's super important at least as
of this moment where do they see their
life going and what's the best outcome
for you like literally you like if I was
like I'm a crazy genius a that will
actually happen that exact way in a
veiner world or anywhere else what would
happen seriously like tell me the next
five years
or three year left to me give me three
or four bullet points how do I help you
achieve at least of this moment cause
you're going to achieve especially at
this young of an age and what happens in
the macroeconomic climates a lot of this
will change but for me to like for me to
ever do anything I always want to know
what somebody wants to happen and so in
the comments on YouTube and Facebook
would love to know what your a 5-year
plan is even though it's not practical
we love the insight onto where your
head's at um that's it you know
yesterday obviously interesting day
today was a really focused had a lot of
[ __ ] I want to get accomplished I'm
which is nice
did that I went to this Knicks game I
was a lot of fun big win excited about
that and now heading to my next meeting
I'll send a I'll send be rock a quick
little snap of that so you know grinding
man 24/7 hustle life I've enjoyed a I've
enjoyed the feedback from everybody
about seeing the real hustle the stunts
how many didn't believe but anyway